thousands of migrants are stranded in
the adamancy and more than 3000 arrived
on Malaysian and Indonesian shores last
month most of them have been row hanga
muslims from myanmar so why are so many
people risking their lives to flee
religious persecution more than a
million Rohingya live in western Myanmar
mostly in Rakhine State but are denied
basic rights including citizenship over
the last three years sectarian violence
with majority Buddhist has caused more
than 100,000 Raeleen get a plea Myanmar
by steam and since the beginning of this
year the human toll has been hard for
the world to ignore I think if I were
wrong I would want to stay where I was
born I'd want to stay in the land where
my parents had lived but I'd want to
make sure that my government was
protecting me but they're not Myanmar's
government is saying that the migrants
aren't their problem and claimed that
the RO hanga are illegal immigrants from
Bangladesh and there are Bangladeshis in
the same boat literally it's hard to
parse the actual number of RO hinga
verses Bangladeshis migrating but in the
first three months of 2015 more than 25
thousand migrants left Myanmar and
Bangladesh on these dangerous smuggling
boats there are still thousands believed
to be at sea in boats abandoned by human
smugglers this is in large part due to
the crackdown on human trafficking by
Thailand which is a destination country
for the migrants
the Thai government began clamping down
after mass graves of migrants from
Myanmar were discovered along the time
of Asian border the country also
convened an emergency conference at the
end of May with 17 countries in
attendance including Myanmar but no
major progress was made so what are
Myanmar's other neighbors doing at first
Malaysian Indonesia were rejecting the
migrants but with media scrutiny and
international pressure the two countries
are now offering temporary shelter on
the condition that the migrants will be
resettled elsewhere now many are
pressuring the United States to step up
- but the US State Department said
resettling the Rohan go into a third
country is not the solution but rather
the answer to this issue is peace and
stability and citizenship for the ringa
in Rakhine State but it doesn't look
like an end to what Human Rights Watch
called and ethnic cleansing is coming
anytime soon and in what is disappointed
many unsung Sukie the main opposition
leader in Myanmar and Nobel Peace Prize
laureate has been mute on the crisis
they'd sit out there for weeks his
people actor Matt Dillon cast the
spotlight on the plight of the Rohingya
and his visit to the squalid refugee
camps in Rakhine State this week but
Hollywood aside what will it take from
Myanmar to solve this crisis once and
for all
it cannot continue like this we cannot
accept that hundreds of people die when
trying to cross the sea to Europe